spaghetti code is easily avoidable once
you know how to avoid it first though
let's talk about the problem things get
really messy when you connect things
together and an application is
ultimately all about connecting pieces
of code to each other but if you connect
all the pieces to all the other pieces
suddenly you can't move anything around
anymore now you may have noticed that
I'm not on my desk I don't have my
computer everything's white it's
actually a little weird that's because
we're in concept land and the whole
point of concept land is to not think
about code so sit back relax and let's
just talk in concepts and metaphors for
a moment here's a metaphor let's go back
in time to the invention of the
telephone
see when there were only two telephones
things were pretty simple the phones
could connect directly to each other and
then we're done two telephones means one
connection now let's add another now we
have three phones and each phone still
needs to connect to every other phone
that means three connections let's add
another one now we have four phones and
each phone still needs to connect to
every other phone
that's for phones and six connections
now this is a pretty shape here but it's
not very good if you have a bunch of
wires all over the place let's add
several more with ten phones we have a
lot more connections 45 connections in
fact I'll tell you this took me a while
to draw so you can imagine what 11
phones or 15 phones or 20 phones or
2,000 phones would be like so here's a
table of what we've learned so far as it
turns out the number of connections is
ultimately defined by the equation n
times n minus 1 all over 2 where n is
the number of phones now if you're a
math geek this is related to n times n
plus 1 over 2 but in this case n is 1
less than the number of phones so I've
simplified to this equation here so now
that we know that how many connections
would a small town with a population of
2000 have that would be 1 million nine
hundred ninety nine thousand connections
I'm not going to draw this one for you
so how do we build the
in reality I'm sure you probably have a
better solution in your head already
let's make every phone connect to a hub
now how many connections do we need well
if you think about it for every phone
you have it connects to one thing rather
than n number of things let's take a
look at our chart again if we have two
phones our number of connections will be
two if we have three phones our number
of connections will be three four phones
will be four ten will be ten and two
thousand will be two thousand as you can
see with two and with three phones we
end up actually doing better off or the
same with our original direct connection
method but generally speaking this shows
you that connections are complexity if
you saw these two things on a graph this
one would go kind of like that this one
would linearly increase so now we know
that we should minimize our connections
it turns out software development is
very similar so let's take a look at
that